One reason that we use four by four matrices to store transforms is that a
single matrix can hold any number of transforms at once. As an example, consider
object three D's rotation paratmeter. Here is a snipet of code from the oil
angler demo. The airplane's three rotation axis are already set. This means that
the airplane is first rotated around its z axis then its y axis, then x.
Internally a transform matrix is made for each rotation. Then these are
multiplied together. Matrix multiplication works like this. For each location in
the resulting matrix, you take the corresponding row of the first matrix.
[inaudible] And the column of the second matrix, and perform a dot product
between these two. For example, to compute element n two four, I compute the dot
product of the fourth row of the first matrix, and the second column of the
second matrix. This gives this set of terms here, added together gives n two
four, 16 dot products later and you have the resulting matrix. To multiply
together our three rotation matrices. We can start at either end. Multiplying Rx
by Ry or Ry by Rz. I've decided to start with Ry and Rz. Multiplying these
together we get some temporary matrix U. We can then multiply together the X
rotation matrix by this temporary matrix. This gives us another matrix call it Q
which consists of all three rotation matrices multiplied together. This
resulting matrix Q can then be used to transform coordinates when an object
coordinate is transformed by this single matrix the coordinate in fact is
rotated by the three rotation matrices in turn it's clearly more efficient to
use a single matrix than three. The scale and translation parameters in the
object 3-d class do the same thing. They create matrices and these all get
multiplied together. Here's the full sequence of transforms that happen for an
object 3-d when using its parameters: scale, the 3 rotations, and translate.
Internally, these matrices are all multiplied together to give a single
resulting matrix m. The parameter in the object 3D class, is, in fact, called
matrix. You can now see why I've been listing the order of matrices as from
right to left. As this is the order we use for multiplying them together.
Multiplying matrices together like this is called concatenation.